[Music]
linda is in
los angeles hi linda welcome to the dave
ramsey show
hi it's actually very funny i just
bumped into your channel for the first
time on youtube and i'm hearing people
ask for advice so
i really need some major advice i'm
going almost going through a divorce and
because of financial issues um bottom
line is i was a single mom with two boys
before i remarried
um as a single mom i was scared to lose
my kids to the streets so i made them a
promise and told them that if they
went to college full time as long as god
blessed me with health and employment
i would financially take care of them
while they completed school
so they kept their end of the deal they
got accepted into really great schools
and i wanted to as a mom to keep my end
of the deal problem is i got remarried
and my husband's completely against me
helping them financially
they're now 22 i'm sorry 24 and 21
one has one semester left at ucla i'm
sorry at tcu
the next one has a year left at ucla so
have you supported them all this time
i have okay good and he doesn't want he
doesn't they're and they're almost done
and he's he's objecting to you finishing
the support
100 he will not contribute financially
to our family
because he's upset that i contribute
towards my children but just
the main point that i was calling about
was i don't ask him for anything i pay
for everything for my children he's
never had to contribute anything towards
their school
towards any of their expenses but his
frame of thinking is
i'm not going to contribute to the
family if you're contributing to your
children that already over 20 you need
to cut
the string and they need to fly on their
own but i told them i made this promise
and i just really want to finish it for
them
so he was like it's the kids or our
marriage so i'm just
we're literally he just moved out a few
months ago and i'm just i'm just
literally torn because i don't know what
to do but
i i mean i do know what to do i want to
continue helping my children
yeah yeah i'm sorry i'm sorry yeah
linda i'm just i'm really sorry you're
in this situation it hurts
you know and um am i wrong am i wrong no
you're not you're not wrong i am no
you're not wrong no
and he tells me all the time because i'm
a christian woman and you say tells me
this all the time
you're christian and you need to submit
your husband and if i don't approve of
it
um you need to respect them let me help
you let me help you with this okay if
your husband's doing cocaine
and wants you to pay for it and he says
you're supposed to submit to me
then that's not what the bible's talking
about okay
so submit does not mean endorsing
misbehavior
okay that's not what it means uh
at all and so uh he probably needs to
get a little better
bible study going because he didn't
understand that concept
but um and he probably needs to get the
idea that you're supposed to like
serve each other and now what i'm
interested in
and number one let me just tell you i
don't think this is gonna go well
with what you've described i think
you're i think i think you're on the
path
of your marriage ending and let me help
you it is not
because you supported your children okay
your marriage is ending because it was
not built on
mutual respect and agreement
your marriage is ending because you had
made a deal prior to getting married
he knew about that deal and then after
getting married
was not okay with it and tried to change
it
and punished you for it and punished you
for it so your marriage is not ending
because you're supporting your kids
he's framing the narrative that way
to try to box you into your choosing
between me and them
but that's not what's happening at all
that's not
that's not it at all it this has to do
with him not getting his little way
and that's what's going on it's
incredibly manipulative as well
like like to see john believes to say
that you have to choose between
supporting an adult child or me is
incredibly new
before you got married yeah he he is the
one that is spinning up this narrative
and put you in this position that is not
actually what's going on
and he put you in this position you did
not put yourself in this position
so uh if you're my little sister linda i
would here's what i would tell you to do
i would tell you to be sure you are
seeing a marriage counselor
and if he wants to go that it would be
great you can have
a mediator to try to help you guys learn
through
how to communicate and how to um
work and navigate through things we
disagree on
okay and if he won't go you should go
anyway because you need someone in your
corner reminding you that you're not
crazy and you're not wrong
okay okay and uh if you're not in a good
church
get in one and you need to get in touch
with the church staff
and sit with a pastor and tell them
what's going on
so you've got people praying for you
that love you well
and that are explaining that submission
does not mean endorsing
misbehavior or endorsing
bad concepts uh you know i i've been
married 38 years
as a believer as a person of faith
and i have never one time told my wife
she needed to do
something because that i wanted her to
do
because she was supposed to submit i
don't have to
it doesn't come up um and because we're
in agreement
we're communicating we're navigating the
decision making together
and she knows i have her best interest
at heart we don't know that about your
husband
he does not seem to have your best
interests at heart he seems to be
selfish
with the story you've told anyway so no
you're not crazy darling
you're just going through hell and uh
i'm sorry
it hurts and it hurts to be torn between
to be put in a position that you feel
like you're torn between two different
competing relationships and that's not
fair
and it it's wrong especially there's no
way he doesn't know this deal happened
prior
you know he didn't come into this blind
no so
uh that's so hard hurtful so hard
here's what i will tell you guys out
there uh it seems like we've had a
little bit of a marriage
uh our theme today uh christy we have
experienced this
that uh you know i use proverbs 31 a lot
who can find a virtuous wife for her
worth is far above rubies the heart of
her husband
safely trusts her and he
will have no lack of gain now for you
ladies that means virtuous
it does not give you permission to be
the holy spirit that's not your job
uh you're virtuous and you're kind and
you're thoughtful
and you're you're smart and you're
entrepreneurial and you're energetic
and you're adding value to the
conversation
and when sharon ramsey does that because
she has done that for 38 years
is one of the reasons we're so vastly
freaking successful here
is that that that pulling together thing
that unity
thing and um to discount
the voice of
either spouse is just it's uh
it's so destructive it does not work and
it does not cause success
yeah and and it's amazing too how i feel
like there's
like what i hear in some of those
conversations from linda it's like
he wants to be respected he wants to be
submitted to whatever
but he's not taking actions that are
worthy of respect or submission and
anytime any man throws around you need
to submit to me because the bible says
that's a red flag right there could i
just say that because the men that you
want to follow are not men that are
throwing that around and it's not the
way that you
love and lead in a marriage using that
kind of language
punishing your wife i'm not going to
contribute to the fam family financially
because you're doing something i don't
like
okay there's and so i think that one of
the things that
even just as we're kind of talking about
this and it applies to lots of marriages
not just the unity piece and the
communication
piece but the respect piece respecting
that other person's voice
respecting their values being willing to
lean into the conflict and have the
conversation until you can get on the
same page versus i'm just going to do
whatever i want to do don't make
decisions at the ramses
of size without being in agreement
and right at this moment we have a
decision that she and i
are not in agreement on and so when
we're not in agreement
what we do is nothing that's right you
know the other person's might be like
well too bad see you later i'm just
gonna go do what i want to that's
it's such a healthy thing to sit in that
because it shows the person i love you
enough to work through this with you
because i want to do it with you right
then not with you
i'm going to wait on you to catch up
please i want you to see my side please
but we just you know if there's a
charity and a ministry we're going to
give to
one of us doesn't feel good about it we
don't until we do enough research or get
more options and
both of us either don't feel good about
it then or both of us start to feel good
about it
and then we can move forward but we have
to have agreement to move forward on
major financial decisions when you don't
you're going to struggle financially
yeah